[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dès la mi mars on pourrait commencer à
se poser sérieusement la question du
port du masque en intérieur chez les
adultes et chez les enfants dans les
transports travaille probablement c'est
vrai que c'est bien qu'à une cinquante
jours de l'élection présidentielle on
annonce la levée de toutes les
restrictions
on peut y voir un lien quand même très
intéressé de la part du président de la
république il ferait mieux se déclarer
candidat et d'entrer en campagne la
question du pass vaccinale peut-être pas
dans tous les milieux peut-être qu'on
gardera à ce moment là le pass vaccinale
dans les endroits à fort risque de
contamination c'était pas un meeting
réussi faut dire les choses comme elles
sont elles font pas tout excuser non
plus par le fait d'être femme est un
exercice où il faut le reconnaître dans
lequel valérie n'excelle pas elle est
plutôt très efficace lorsqu'elle est en
plateau télé ou efficace en réunion en
question réponse la norme multiséculaire
de ce que les sociologues du pouvoir
appelle l'homme blanc réputé hétéro et
donc comme nous sommes ni des hommes ni
nous ne sommes pas dans cette catégorie
fait pas les donner
cherche t on à tout au bruit pour
critiquer les hoquets enfin c'est
parfois la critique quand elle est un
peu excessive assez vite de l'autre côté
de red le côté obscur de la force ça m'a
fait mal pour la politique parce que ça
m'a rappelé la trahison d'eric besson
d'un autre éric et ribeyrolles et eric
votre observation c'est pas un
débauchage seuil à 20 traîtrise alors
c'est bon
aliment mais là se rallier à l'autre
alors évidemment il n'ira rechi là
dedans
évidemment il ya un moment donné où vous
n'êtes pas des rendez vous est une
esclave je suis pas un esclave nicolas
bay une taupe c'est ce qu'affirme le
bureau exécutif du rassemblement
national qu'il accuse de servir les
intérêts d'eric zemmour nous avons eu
confirmation que nicolas bay transmet
depuis des mois des éléments
stratégiques et confidentielles à notre
concurrent direct
eric zemmour il nie désormais les torts
portées contre lui l'accusation est
grossière ne participant à aucune
instance de la direction de campagne
comment aurais-je pu connaître et
transmettre de prétendues informations
stratégiques will a transmis des
informations contrairement à ce qui dit
participer aux réunions de campagne il
était sur la conversation
rennard guyaz le fond il ya le programme
mais il ya aussi un calendrier qu'on
essaie de mettre en place pour pouvoir
communiquer ses idées le mieux possible
c'est pitoyable c'est ridicule c'est
minable je veux dire là on est rentré
dans une guerre dont profite tout le
monde sauf nous on est là à penser que
il m'a transmis des éléments de la
stratégie de marine le pen c'est oss 117
d'abord quelle stratégie oui il ya une
stratégie de marine le pen la stratégie
qu'a mise en place eric zemmour qu'une
stratégie de la provocation qu'une
stratégie brutale qui ne sera tj du buzz
qui en fait lui reconstitué au dessus
lui un plafond de verre que nous avions
nous ya quelques années
peut trouver un écho avec le discours
qu'avait le front national il ya 20 ou
30 ans vous avez confié au magazine elle
que vous verriez bien marion maréchal à
matignon non monsieur jeu doom traite de
juif de service monsieur zemmour là pour
le coup il n'y a pas de grand débat
public alors qu objectivement réagissent
et les figures de style des figures de
style antisémites ne sont jamais un bon
discours me semble-t-il et je sais la
grande différence qui me séparent de
monsieur zemmour mais j'ai été
profondément choqué les journalistes de
elle m'ont demandé est-ce que vous
verriez une femme à matignon crédit
évidemment pourquoi pas on me dit marion
maréchal je réponds pourquoi pendant sa
devient marion maréchal sera le premier
ministre d'eric zemmour philippe
maréchal et coiffeurs et maire de
balagny sur terrain ville de 1700
habitants l'élu a pris une décision en
solide il s'est auto parrainé pour
l'élection présidentielle c'est un
avertissement qui fait tâche sur la page
wikipedia de marlène schiappa et cet
article semble être une page
autobiographique ou autocentré en clair
la ministre fait régulièrement modifié
sa page pour effacer des passages gênant
et promouvoir son action révèle un média
en ligne c'est simplement pour
effectivement de dire je n'ai pu le voir
distribuer donc voilà